today's be us bite is 300 that's the
number of new gs300 the new emojis
included in Apple's newest update of iOS
8.3 and these will give a range of skin
colors and add a bunch of different
things in there to address some of the
diversity criticism that Apple has
gotten since it introduced emojis into
its natives text back in 2011 what the
world isn't full of just white dudes no
the world is in full of just white dudes
and apples you know letting letting
people know that they're using something
called the Fitzpatrick scale which is
what skin experts actually use and they
picked five colors there's still been
some criticism out there that they're
not doing enough but it's definitely a
step for them in terms of integrating
some more look into these emojis I know
I love you'll see in my twitter feed so
i'll be a happy lady to see some of
these new characters in my feed i will
look forward to deciphering your your
lengthy emoji Tex Alex I will tell
summary via emoji only just for you Cory
don't worry